but tonight we are very honored to have
a former CIA and natural archives member
David Rogers here with us talking about
his book creating the secret state for
those of you who like me are devotees of
PBS cooking shows the CIA here of course
is the Central Intelligence Agency and
not the Culinary Institute of America so
if any of you have made that mistake we
do ask that you still stay and listen
but a lot has been written about the CIA
but not too much on how it was created
and what the truth behind the creation
of the CIA is and there's a lot of myths
and misunderstandings about it so to
help us shed some light and understand
this agency a little better is mr. David
Rogers and I thank thank you all for
turning out on the first day of summer
it warms the heart of an old bureaucrat
to see people turn out their hear mouth
off since Washington is the literary
scene here is full of books about inside
insiders on government government
activities perhaps my book fits into
that kind of genre although I write
about an activity that the government
became involved in some 60 years ago the
founding of the Central Intelligence
Agency now it's what I call the founding
myth of the Central Intelligence Agency
that the organization was the unique
brainchild of Wild Bill Donovan the
director of the wartime Office of
Strategic Services and that he brought
his creation through to reality over the
objections of a large number of
troglodytes within the government and
that the CIA is the direct linear a
lineal heir
of the OSS well the truth in fact is a
little bit more prosaic and the fact is
that the Central Intelligence Agency
came about as a result of a perceived
institutional need among government
policymakers for some sort of
intelligence coordination after World
War two while Bill Donovan himself had
nothing to do with the establishment of
the central intelligence organization
and there was no intention at any time
to recreate the wartime OSS that that
the CIA eventually became something
looking like the wartime OSS was
essentially a series of coincide and
events again okay which came about
against the background of the cold
emerging Cold War I first came on this
topic a number of years ago when I was
working down the street at the National
Archives I had no idea at the time that
I'd ever be in CIA and I was involved in
one of the first projects of the US
government to declassify all the
classified records that the government
had generated since during in since
world war ii this has since become a
major cottage industry and the federal
government and i was very surprised to
see all the documents that the reviewers
were turning up on the establishment of
a post war intelligence system and I was
interested enough in this topic to want
to pursue some research in it which the
National Archives allowed me to do and I
poked around and the other records in
the central and to end the National
Archives in the Bureau of the budget the
war Navy departments the State
Department Joint Chiefs of Staff and
also various obscure congressional
hearings that were also held as the
archives that I knew the literature at
the time such that it was and I also
knew the glorious history of Wild Bill
Donovan and the OSS and of course what
struck me at the time was that how
little while Bill Donovan actually had
to do with the process so when I when I
can put completed taking my notes and
started writing up a manuscript I found
I had this monstrosity on my hands that
was too long for an article and too
short for a book and I have actually had
to put the whole project aside to deal
with the exigencies of raising a family
and came back to it around at the
beginning of the 1990s when my wife and
I acquired a country house in the
bucolic Virginia countryside and the
Shenandoah Valley and there that was my
writers retreat in the process I had
left the National Archives and gone to
work at the Central Intelligence Agency
where I spent the next 22 years as
mainly as an editor and a intelligence
analyst and while at the CIA I was of
course hit right in the face with the
the Donovan cult of personality which is
very pronounced and it was even more is
even more pronounced now than then and I
also came across the sacred text of the
Donovan cult of personality a book
called Donovan and the CIA the founding
a history of the establishment of the
Central Intelligence Agency by a
contractor named Thomas Troy that's the
gentleman referred to on the blurb on
the back of the book I read mr. Troy's
book though and although he was an
excellent researcher he did not write a
book about the founding of the CIA what
he wrote a book about was the Adventures
of Wild Bill Donovan in darkest war-time
Washington with several superficial
chapters added at the end as an after
what and I also after I resumed my work
I finished the records at the National
Archives that I hadn't looked at before
including I should add the working
papers of Thomas Troy that who had been
retired to the to the archives by the
CIA and were very if he had used all
that material that he collected I
wouldn't be standing here talking
tonight as a matter of fact but he saved
me a great deal of effort I also
explored various other sets of sets of
records the I went down to the
University of Virginia library which is
just over the hill from Harrisonburg and
they used the papers of Secretary of
State Edward Stettinius which were very
valuable source for early state
department thinking a chapter four of my
book is about the State Department and
its its involvement in the issue and I
made a pilgrimage up to the Army
Historical Institute in Carlisle
barracks to look at the Donovan papers
they were interesting but not not not
earth-shaking
and I unlike the Stettinius Papers they
were in very poor condition so if there
anybody here who wants to honor mr.
Donovan they should land on the army
very hard to put those papers into some
kind of order because the and proper
proper condition before they completely
disintegrate and I spent a very pleasant
week at the Truman library and
Independence Missouri and I was
fortunate enough when the State
Department published a volume in its
what's called as foreign relations
series on the establishment of the
post-war central intelligence system in
this country that was a thousand pages
of documents most of most of which had
never seen the light of day before
and so out of out of all this this
research came the book and my basic
conclusion that I stated that while Bill
Donovan did not have any role in the
establishment of the Central
Intelligence Agency well this is not a
throat grabbing revelation to a lot of
historians I suppose but I can guarantee
around the Central Intelligence Agency
it's a view somewhat akin to treason
blast for me and sacrilege but no no
historian has bothered addressing this
issue the way as I did in any of their
books and some of them like John Ron ley
who wrote the only complete history of
the CIA but did a great deal to
perpetrate this this founding myth what
happened was this when the world war two
entered its terminal phase the United
States was clearly emerging as the were
the first the the first power in the
world so the issue of how would the
United States face advantage its renew
responsibilities became a very important
one in the government and in the among
the general public and there was
essentially a division of labor the
State Department focused on the issues
of international affairs multinational
activities which through things like the
United Nations and the Bretton Woods and
organizations that it set up while the
military establishment or the war Navy
departments and the Joint Chiefs of
Staff focused on how the government
would cope with what we call today
national security management and out and
of course since legislation would be
required Congress was very much involved
in this in a variety of hearings and
studies and out of this this interest
emerged what was essentially an
executive legislative consensus
on how the new system should be set up
and this consensus was an idea a series
of ideas loosely based on the British
War Cabinet system the there would be
univ so called unification of the armed
forces under a some sort of Department
of National Defense the Joint Chiefs of
Staff would be legally established by
law and there would be an interagency
Council which would deal with
coordinating and bringing together the
diplomatic military and other activities
that go into foreign policymaking and
this council would be served by a
variety of specialized bodies for
scientific research and development war
mobilization and central intelligence
coordination this clear statement of
this came with the so called Ebor stat
report of September 1945 this was
prepared by a New York banker and
businessman named Ferdinand II burst at
at the direction of Secretary of the
Navy James Forrestal who acted on a
suggestion by the chairman of the Senate
naval Affairs Committee does senator
Walsh of Massachusetts this is that this
is the clearest statement public
publicly of any of a proposal for a
Central Intelligence Agency they used
that very term as part of a NIA as part
of a national security management system
and to show how the federal governor I
acted to this I have to back up a little
bit and point out that the war may
required that the Army and Navy work
together on a variety of things and they
did this to of all sorts of joint boards
and committees including joint
intelligence committees the primary one
was on the attach to the Joint Chiefs of
Staff and
the being sensible men they decided that
this would be carried over into the
post-war and also that they were they
took this view as because of what Dean
Acheson lady referred to as a defensive
alliance against William J Donovan and
the OSS because Donovan although he
headed what was essentially a temporary
agency he had he had very clear
ambitions of post-war permanence and his
organization was a very freewheeling
outfit and together the man in the
organization had their feet in just
about every plate in Washington so and
the upshot of all this was came on
October the 23rd 1944 when the Joint
Chiefs of Staff issued a paper called
post-war intelligence policy of the
United States this is the first official
statement of policy for a calling for a
post-war Central Intelligence Agency
again this is that that was the thief or
the name which would be part of a which
would be subordinate to a National
Intelligence Council made up of the
secretaries of state war Navy and the
joini representative Joint Chiefs of
Staff it had very specific very limited
powers and and this this was this was
put forward as the official position of
the military establishment at the time
however Donovan of course or a real
challenge to his own own own views of
post-war central intelligence so he
Lobby so he decided to play his his ace
in the hole which was presidential
patronage so he lobbied Franklin
Roosevelt for a request to present his
views and such a review a request was
forthcoming and on November 18th 1944
about three weeks after the JCS he he
submitted to President Roosevelt a
document called the basis for a
permanent u.s. foreign intelligence
service and this was essentially calling
for a post-war OSS which was doing a
variety of things intelligence analysis
a secret intelligence collection
propaganda bird propaganda and something
Donovan called subversive operations
abroad which today we know is covert
activity and Donovan just to try and get
FDR to present his opponents with a fait
accompli included a draft directive to
set the thing up which he hoped
Roosevelt would do with here what he did
in 1942 with the OSS this time FDR
didn't buy into it he merely referred
Donovan's proposal to the Joint Chiefs
of Staff for consideration through his
his debt his military deputy Admiral
William de l'Est naturally the Joint
Chiefs of Staff didn't care for the
proposal at all they fell back on their
own plan and specifically didn't like
this talk about subversive operations
abroad so while the thing well the
debate was going on Donovan was seething
and the issue was resolved in perhaps
the real war classic Washington
fashioned a press leak in February 1945
somebody passed the Donovan proposal in
the state and the Joint Chiefs of Staff
proposals to a very vocal anti
administration journalist named walter
tro han who published who published a
series of very lurid articles about it
in the old Washington Times Herald which
was a very strident anti administration
newspaper and this complete this
essentially ended the ended the proposed
ended consideration of the proposals
Donovan was furious and you read in my
quote correspondence that he wrote to
the President on this he never caught on
to the fact that the man who was
responsible for the leak was Franklin
Roosevelt
himself but as things do in Washington
this is the this blue over and to
mollify Donovan the president decided
that he should resubmit his proposals to
the cabinet's secretaries for
consideration in egg and in April and
Donovan dutifully did so and flew off to
Europe
FDR headed off to Warm Springs Georgia
and on April 12 1945 the four senior
cabinet officers met in what is now the
executive office building right across
street from the White House to consider
this proposal they in the course of
their meeting they rejected Donovan's
proposals again outright and decided
that they'd start over from scratch in
the course of the meeting Secretary of
State Stettinius received a phone call
from the come over to the White House
and there he was told that Franklin
Roosevelt had just died that ended the
meeting that ended and that ended
Donovan's dreams for the future right
then and there we all know that Truman
in September abolished the OSS as a
century as a temporary or government
organization its functions were
distributed between the War Department
and the State Department and that that
didn't that is that at this point as I
like to point instance mr. point out
this removed Donovan completely from the
policy making
activity any positive making activities
he plays except for some marginal
kibbutz thing he plays no further role
and in the establishment of a Central
Intelligence Agency why because he was
out of step with the legislative
executive consensus and Truman didn't
like him anyway so that was he so he was
essentially could perhaps be considered
the Godfather but
like Moses he remained outside the
promised land and could only look in so
but that but there was still an interest
in some sort of central intelligence
organization and the government and
Truman when he abolished the OSS had
said that at given directions the
Secretary of State burns that the State
Department should take the lead well as
I described in Chapter four the State
Department blew its opportunity to
become the chief foreign intelligence
organization of the center of the United
States government in through a variety
of internal disputes over how thee in
the department's intelligence
organization was going to be organized
and in the meantime what happened was in
September of 1945 as the OSS was
breathing its last Admiral Leahy revived
the Joint Chiefs of Staff proposal and
submitted it to the White House through
the War Navy Department and this
proposal was in line with the thinking
of the Secretary of us of the Navy
Forrestal and also with the people in
the War Department and they the two
departments supported this plan and
thought it forded the bureaucratic
system as I described in Chapter five
against a few against other proposals
there was a one from the Justice
Department and then from the Bureau of
the budget that was sort of very much
also-rans but there was quite a fight
over one that was proposed by the State
Department and in the end on nanjiang on
January to date down here January 22nd
1946 Truman issued a directive
establishing the new Central
Intelligence Agency a new Central
Intelligence system it was essentially a
a slightly revised form of what the
Joint Chiefs of Staff has has had to had
urge their instead of a Joint Chiefs of
Staff representative there would be a
personal representative of the President
of the United States that would be
William de Leahy
again the organizers of this
intelligence organization was
responsible what's called the Central
Intelligence Group and it was
responsible to a National Intelligence
Authority made up of Leahy and the force
and the three cabinet secretaries and
this organization was responsible got
its personnel and its funding from the
three cabinet offices so the and Truman
as the his first director of central
intelligence agency central intelligence
appointed a man named Sidney sours who
was such a low-key operator that it's
easy to overlook how important he was he
was a businessman who was a call to
active duty in the Navy and Ray arose to
Rear Admiral and it was became deputy of
onr Office of Naval Intelligence and he
was a Missourian and although he was
never a crony of Truman's he was the
kind of man Truman really trusted and
even in his very short tenure he got the
basic authorities down and set the
wheels of organization in motion that
his successor could build upon and he
was most shrewd and picking his
successor
a man named General Hoyt Vandenberg who
was a dashing army flyboy and very
energetic very able man and even though
he was only also only in position the
position of Director of Central
Intelligence a short time he was a man
who knew how to make hay while the Sun
was shining and because the government
was retrenching he went about and in
gathered everything dealing with
intelligence that he could find from
anybody he got the remnants of the
OSs secret intelligence units from the
back from the army and got the
responsibility for atomic energy
intelligence again from the army when
the because they had to get rid of it
and he even bested J Edgar Hoover in a
bureaucratic battle which is indeed
something Bill Donovan never managed to
do so he he you know in a real sense is
the founder of the city is a founder of
the CIA
however the CI G because suffered from
its problems not being not having its
own budget and personnel system and also
it wasn't legal because it wasn't backed
by legislation so this became the next
the next issue for the national security
managers that I mentioned in chat I
discussed in Chapter eight of my book
this this requires this require and this
of course like many things do in
Washington led to a bureaucratic fight
Vandenberg and the so called
intelligence professionals wanted a
piece of free-standing legislation that
specifically set up a Central
Intelligence Agency by itself while the
the basic White House position was to
build essentially he put the Central
Intelligence Agency in the context of a
broader national security management
status system and the so this led to a
rather straw a nasty bureaucratic fight
between Vandenberg and the man who was
responsible for writing the legislation
a chap named Clark Clifford who I think
everybody in this room has heard of and
clifford of course won and the upshot
was the national security act of july 26
1947 and on September 18 1947 the
Central Intelligence Agency opened for
business now I couldn't leave that just
at this point the
thinking well the millennia has arrived
so we need no longer look at it because
the CIA that was described in the
enabling legislation in 1947 bore note
boy he bears no resemblance to the CIA
that for that that had developed in the
post-war years and exists today so in
Chapter nine of my book I I just I draw
you picked the four episodes that I
think explain why the CIA became what it
did and what it what it would now look
what it now but now is based on the
against against the background of the
Cold War the first was the investing the
investigations of 1948 that were
prompted by the growing pains that the
CIA suffered this these investigations
one by the Hoover Commission the first
Hoover Commission of the Congress and
the second by a internal executive
committee headed by Allen Dulles again a
figure I don't don't have to say much
about in this town and these these two
studies laid out the base of what was
considered but what I go to add elegance
organization ought to be the second
major episode was the passage in 1949 of
the law as describing the mission and
function and responsibilities of the CIA
separate from the rest of the national
security establishment which is what the
CIA had wanted to begin with and that
basically established the authority of
the central intelligence agency to be a
DBA to be a secret the secret
intelligence organization particularly
where money is concerned and money is
the root of all things particularly in
the
and when governance is concerned the
third episode which I described in
Chapter nine and also in a spin-off
article that I've written is the
invention of covert operations as a
foreign policy standards for ontology to
love the American government which was
consistently used during the Cold War as
an instrument of American overseas
engagement and the fourth incident was
the incumbency of of General Walter
Bedell Smith as director of Central
Intelligence Vandenberg was succeeded by
a Navy admiral named Roscoe Hillen
Cotter who was a good sailor but
certainly not a very good player in the
Washington power game and not a good spy
master so he he rose without a trace
however Smith was the essentially the
drill master of the Central Intelligence
Agency because he gave it its its
present form structure and mission and
after and essentially its marching
orders so at this at this point with
Smith's tenure the CIA became the modern
organization that it has remained and
this these four events as I as I
conclude in my book led to the CIA
trapeze basically being transformed from
an intelligence gathering organization
to a instrument of fighting the Cold War
to project American foreign policy and
is some irreverent people would say sort
of the goon squad of American hegemony
so and this of this of course gave
Donovan the ultimate victory in the in
the fight over intelligence of the
organization but it was a partial
victory because the other branches of
government still particularly in the
military establishments
will retained their own intelligence
organizations so the CIA was never as
supreme as Donovan dreamed it to be and
also Donovan's victory as I concluded my
book was a victory loaded with irony
because since the CIA became essentially
a cold war fighting instrument when the
Cold War ended so unexpectedly and the
evil empire collapsed of its own accord
the Central Intelligence Agency was left
without a role without him and a real
mission and it's now faced with the
problem of reinventing itself and this
problem was exacerbated because these
events on the international scene
occurred amid massive scandals within
the CIA so there was no sense of
triumphalism mainly a sense of
uncertainty and foreboding within the
CIA I was there I could see it it almost
cut it but as I have to but I will say
that the present present incumbent as
the director of Central Intelligence
George Tennant is well aware of this
problem is well aware of the fact that
the CIA has to reinvent itself or it did
not and not only will cease to be useful
it will might even cease to exist
however mr. Tennant has made very clear
in numerous speeches and public
statements that under his brilliant
leadership the corner has been turned
and the great and great new days are
ahead
I don't know I'm retired now so this
this may be the case but only time will
tell and thank you and if I'll take any
questions if you have some yes sir this
man in the back there you
yeah okay oh I have two questions one
dealing with the original period from 40
to 45 at which time Ho Chi Minh's
was cooperating with the American
intelligence and getting the information
on the Japanese intrusions into French
Indochina now which later became of
course mainly in Vietnam and my question
is was the relative disorganization and
conflict of the role of intelligence
adversely affect our ability to
understand what was going on in Vietnam
at that time and whether we made serious
mistakes
the second question has to do with
fighting the Cold War is my
understanding in 67 to 70 when Biafra
became independent of Nigeria the CIA
supported Biafra
but in the end kissing her in the State
Department overruled them and said that
we must maintain stability above all and
that no breakups are to be allowed and
and that has been the consistent policy
pretty much ever since that this was a
turning point in vampire I want your
opinion although basically when a french
indochina during world war ii was pretty
much terra incognita at the american
policy makers FDR basically said he
didn't want the french going back and
but these OSS was operating all over all
over creation where they could get
somebody in and in the earth the closing
days of world war ii they did have
people in in in vietnam essentially and
they were me there's a man named Archie
Mattie's Patty who was meeting with Ho
Chi Minh and was actually there when
when they proclaimed independence the
first time in Hanoi and patty of course
wrote has written a good book he died a
couple of years ago called why Vietnam
describing one of the several describing
those those events and he was there for
a lot of it and basically the OSS
was was sympathetic to the Vietnamese
nationalism but the government of course
as the Cold War came along took took a
pro French spin and the old ideas of
returning of letting Vietnam go or
abandoned simply out of the Cold War
necessity as far as Biafra goes that was
in the 60s I don't think Kissinger was
doing much then but the you know US
government did support the independence
of Nigeria because like you say it was
US policy to try and keep these
countries together because once they
start falling apart nothing nothing
stops them and of course the French just
sort of international kibbutz thing were
involved did promote by a foreign
independence but not enough not enough
to really fully help them but and of
course we were bogging down in Indochina
at the time so the the brigade we pretty
much let the British call the tunes as
far as Biafra go there's a good book on
the bio from the Nigerian civil war came
out a number of years ago called I think
the brothers war by John Dee Saint is
off or something like that it's a very
good very good day sort of instant
history account of of the the war in
night in Nigeria but it has like you say
it has been the policy of the United
States to back the territorial integrity
of of any of these countries simply
because the alternative is complete
disintegration Sharon you had a question
is
50 and when the Korean War started why
wasn't the CIA more effective why didn't
we win and finalize well because one
thing Douglas MacArthur kept kept the
CIA out of Japan just like he kept it
out of this just like he kept it out of
the South Pacific Theater during World
War two he didn't he didn't didn't like
anybody's intelligence officers except
his own and he had a man who and his
intelligence chief was was a boob who
spent most of his time looking for
subversives in Japan and of course we
down to 1950 we regret we wrote off-road
off Korea and then suddenly has changed
our minds when the war broke out and
rather than risk a larger war we were
willing to settle for what some would
call a standoff and others would call a
defense of victory and in Korea and yes
everybody yes yes I understand you had a
debate with at the archive yes what was
his response to what you are presenting
in your Park and great indignation he he
was very objected very much to the quote
on the back of the book from what Wesley
walk and I told him that I did not put
war cup to saying that and he he
apparently doesn't play bridge because
he didn't know what out trumped meant
and then he praised his own book volubly
and that demanded to know why after
thriving for 22 years at the CIA
I was so Akana clastic and why I had
such a liberal bias and I I said I make
no apologies for any liberal bias and
afterward I kind of clastic because I
spent 22 years at CIA on the shop floor
with the working stiffs and as Yogi
Berra is to say you can see a lot by
looking
though any any other gray gentlemen the
back oh what's your observation as far
as the
early interaction between the CIA and
the elites around the world as far as
the academics and artists and scholars I
don't know if you had a reaction to the
recent book by Francis donor son yes I I
had I just picked the book up I haven't
read it yet and I it's an old it's an
old story basically Saunders I think as
her facts right but she she takes a
slightly his hysterical tone in my view
this is one time when the CIA was sort
of on the right doing the right thing
because the Cold War did have a cultural
a sculptural element to it and and being
being there being the patron of the Arts
is not a bad thing to do as long as the
degree of control is on what the artists
do is not is not major and trying to
control those kind of artists that the
CIA was secretly supporting was like
hurting squirrels it's rather difficult
thing to do and it's not-- probably no
otter than Edsel Ford subsidizing Diego
Rivera the Mexican Communist painter so
maybe it does bother people who who
don't like the idea of government and
arts and particularly secret
manipulation but in the context of the
time perhaps it was understandable inin
and to my mind it's a lot better than
organs in supporting death squads in
Central America or or training the
Iranian secret police how to torture
people or things like that
so the compared to something or giving
people drugs without telling them I mean
some some things are quite unsavory this
is this is not too bad we're very
influenced on religion
leaders well I imagine a lot of
religious leaders were did did talk with
with with with CIA personnel at one at
one time or another and whether whether
the and of course the Catholic Church of
course at the time was very militantly
anti-communist in the 50s I mean
Cardinal Spellman was a leading
political figure as well as a religious
leader probably more more than for the
former than the latter I think on some
occasions so I don't doubt that he he he
knew various various people and John
McCone was a very prominent lay Catholic
leader so these these connections get
get around as far as who is passing
money to whom I really don't know
another question yes sir you mentioned
in provide my questioning that you need
that you have companies in supporting
stability around the world do you think
it's justified now that the Cold War is
over
is shouldn't we support nations that
want to be independent of oppression by
another nation within a territorial
state why should we be so concerned
anymore about break up of the huge
states that are oppressing the people
within it
oh we reverse our policy or do you think
so you agree with the continuation of
the stability for me well not only think
Madeleine Albright has it has a good
answer for that one so I'm not sure I
can come up with its a it is a new it is
a new wrinkle for American policymakers
to to or to to have to face problems
like this if these new new emerging of
ethnic ethnic nationalism within
countries but here again if you support
it how how far - how far do you push it
we could turkey turkey we can supported
Kurdish independence and Iran Iraq for
instance but it's the Turkish Kurds that
are the most that are also very
obstreperous and turkey is an ally and
of course I think because we liked it
because it's better to have friends than
enemies I suppose
and of course how far we're going to
push it are we going to back Quebec
independence with Canada a country which
which we have always have independence
well here again here again we could have
a lovely policy making this is this is
the issue that I can't solve that
tonight and if I if I could I'd be
writing my Nobel Peace Prize speech but
but it is the Hound narrowly do you
split these issues is it is the bay is a
basic issue of a foreign pop host Cold
War foreign policy that nobody has
solved yet so I certainly don't have a
solution for it tonight
any other questions is there someone
mentioned to me recently something about
the Korean War in that the British
inform the Chinese that the US would not
use a Tom
weapons if the Chinese after the war
have you heard anything about front well
no I haven't the avid to tell you to
tell you the truth but it did become
when Truman when they when the front in
Korea collapsed and MacArthur lost his
nerve and everybody was panicking in
Washington Truman Truman as we know was
very was very made elliptical references
to using atomic weapons and at Lee came
flying across the Atlantic and as to
help his help himself politically so so
I but whether the British went back
channel or not I have no I have no idea
but there's this this question was a an
important one for a for a short period
of time at the in 950 51 there before
the front line was stabilized again a
jackass mentioning delineating the
growth of CIA the children didn't like
Donovan and so forth and so on the
heyday seemed to be about 1952 when you
heard Eisenhower who leaned on John
Foster Dulles his brother was head of
CIA whose sister was head of the German
desiccate and budget problems for CIA no
problem at all general Smith was also
Under Secretary of State yes the goal to
see a 50s is the golden age of the CIA
we look back on it we look back on it I
was working when I left it was still the
age of lead so it was looked back on
with a great deal of nostalgia and the
dull of the Peter grosses biography of
Dulles gives a John of Allen Dulles
gives a real sense of that period but
those those were the halcyon days when
the station Chiefs were Pro consuls and
didn't give a damn about what the
Ambassador thought and wheeling and
dealing and of course the the crows came
home to roost eventually but
those are those those are the those are
the days when the old-timers want to
wallow in nostalgia that's that's what
they that's most of it most of them are
dead by now but they did for a long time
I knew some of them when I first started
working at CIA and so those those were
the great those with a great great
golden days of the CIA the 50s certainly
yes ma'am William Casey is director as a
director well Casey was the Minnesota
guys want to look on him sort of there's
a Republican Joe Kennedy he was a very
able hard-working
highly intelligent crafty man just like
Joe Kennedy like Joe Kennedy he didn't
have it and he was probably the last
strong director the CIA that we had at
least the last one prior to George Tenet
and tenants estimation but he was the
last strong leader the CIA I think ever
had
unfortunately he didn't have a scrap of
integrity and he was a ardent cold
warrior so he led where he led the CIA
was off a cliff and today at the bottom
of that cliff you can find the
credibility and the institutional
integrity of the CIA in ruins because
they he brought about of course the CIA
at least elements of it were willing to
were willing to be led off that cliff
but he was that he sort of saw himself
as the new Donovan to lea lead these the
CIA against the new evil empire the way
Donovan and Letty the OSS against the
old evil empire
and things didn't and things didn't work
out quite quite as quite as anticipated
and hehe he's essentially the CIA
institutionally paid a very high price
for for his conduct as as direct I think
some some would say that had he not died
he might have he might have been under
indictment for perjury and conspiracy
but of course it's very easy to dump on
Bill case because he's dead but a lot of
a lot of the things the problems that
since came along or do to him he was he
was a throwback to the golden age like I
was talking to Jack about he was a
throwback to the 50s and the 50s were
over and he didn't he didn't realize it
then and that's basically we're still
playin when I retired me with CIA was
still paying the price for what Bill
Casey did yes sir in the back how would
you characterize the relationship
between the FBI and the CIA from its
beginnings to the current day and I
wonder if you would say anymore about j
edgar hoover i you do portray him in the
book is being very reluctant to get into
this coordination effort except until he
was ordered by roosevelt and you see you
portray him as very protective of his
own turf well he always was he he he
never he was and he was not a man who
gave up power once he got it
he would his good bureaucrat he did
follow orders but once he once he got
his marching orders he they could have
been from Coolidge and until anybody who
specifically repealed them he went by he
went by them and he as a he had his
foreign intelligence apparatus in Latin
America and he knew he essentially felt
he had to give it up when his the
Justice Department scheme wasn't
accepted for
for organization but he did not like the
idea of giving it up and he he made life
very unpleasant and essentially left a
lot of empty files behind file drawers
behind him when he when he abandoned his
the intelligence network in Latin
America and subsequently relations
between the CIA and the FBI are almost
the sort of the negotiation between two
foreign sovereign countries which try to
get along because they must and it's of
course because Hoover is gone now things
are probably rather rather easier and of
course nowadays with with with various
at subjects such as international crime
and terrorism becoming national security
issues the foreign involvement of the
FBI is increasing again in a fashion
that would make junior groover very
happy at the at the expense at the
expense of the CIA so it's always been a
very and of course people would hang
medals on J Edgar Hoover just sort of to
mollify them so it was a very it was a
very contentious relationship with him
because he was something into the strong
portion of American political society he
was something of an icon and it's always
hard to deal with the National Monument
so so things are probably more more
settled now and in fact the like I
mentioned the FBI is gaining a gaining
ground at CIA's expense when it comes to
foreign operations yes sir this
capability how would you rank to say CIA
among stuff I
I drank I drank acquainted quite high
it's of course whether you what you're
what you're going to do what you're
allowed to do and what you will you feel
the need to do and some some things
one's discovered one can't do like
assassinating people the KGB or Mossad
doesn't have those doesn't have those
constraints and and some some some
things the the contributions of course
of the CIA are often in the eye of the
beholder but this is the real American
skill in in in telling and intelligence
activities of the technical aspects and
the CIA was a leader in the such things
as overhead reconnaissance technology
and and so of course and war by
Washington logic the overhead
reconnaissance responsibilities then go
to the Defense Department so but then
this is Washington so but in Sun and of
course old old spooks have told me how
hard it is to convince Americans that
they should go out and spy on other
people when they're when they're
training case officers but I've known
I've known case officers and generally
the quality of the quality they are a
dedicated conscientious lot and remember
it's always the political establishment
that sets that sets that the tone for
what what the CIA can and can't do
people have said that the CIA is a rogue
elephant
well they accurately would use the
pachyderm analogy it's an elephant
driven by a rogue mahout the President
of the United States and so so this is
this is this is a sort of thing that has
to be kept in mind sharing in
question was the CIA ever involved with
the McCarthy period and the Communists
which cut such as Hardy and were they
ever involved with the infiltration of
the anti-vietnam protest well there
isn't too great basically the the CIA
came out sort of on the side of the
Angels with McCarthy because he he was
started when he in his in his glory days
he started to poke around with the with
the CIA and an unlike brother john allen
dulles told him to go bug off and
President Eisenhower back to back Dulles
so the CIA for that for that period of
time became something of a liberal hero
and as far as the anti-war movement goes
the it's now it's known now that the CIA
did look at examined foreign connections
of the of the anti-war movement this is
one of those gray areas where you're
crossing between far foreign and
domestic intelligence and law law
enforcement and of course as Richard
Helms sometimes likes to point out when
an American goes overseas they turn up
as a blip on the radar screen because if
anybody goes abroad and starts talking
to a legitimate intelligence target then
they they get they get noticed and that
can be Angela Davis a congresswoman ABS
UGG or anyone if they're if they're
talking to a foreign intelligence target
then they're they're going to get
noticed and and they they they're
material things on them turn up in the
files and this this is later something
of an embarrassment but that's sort of
you that is essentially what happened
with the CIA yes sir
that last few months or a year or two in
view of being history of jehovah and his
rather extreme measure that he took
prism protections on and then the action
of the FBI at Waco and Ruby Ridge and
Oklahoma City and so on that's been a
consideration of the Attorney General
and the FBI which said loggerheads also
that there be some type of a Federal
Reserve System of long term appointments
to be for the Justice Department and FBI
so that in sort of a group would make
policy in the in this area have you
heard any do you think any woman and in
fact I do I mentioned something in my
book about that because Allen Dulles
when he was made his statement to
Congress about 1947 said that the head
of the CIA what to be a long-term
appointee sort of like a judge above
politics and and of course j edgar
hoover was in place for for decades and
decades because and he when he and and
the when he died was the first effort to
make that a opposed the director of FBI
to be confirmed by the senate because
these are so these are these ideas were
always there but in thank you policy
like the federal reserve system meets
once a month it decides economic policy
that kind of a concept well there isn't
it well there is an intelligence
community type of organization and you
know about you know the old line okay a
camel is a horse designed by a committee
so so that's the so that is this
communal it is that there is a
Committees of air of intelligence or
senior intelligence people do meet and
the titular head of it is the director
of central intelligence but it's he does
he does not give orders to anyone and of
course most of many of the agents
particularly Defense Department the
intelligence resources of the Defense
Department are dwarfed the entire entire
CIA so this this committee structure
were as they're in place and even as we
speak and it works no better than things
usually work in Washington I suppose it
would be asking to a lot of it if I
suppose to do to expect it to into it to
function to function - well because
bureaucratic interests are what are what
they are even the great German General
Staff didn't function all that well so
so so this this system does is it is in
place and there's a big staff to manage
it so there that that exists at the
present time
yes sir again CIA KGB and professionals
and other nations
what do they think of each other well
depends it depends on the organization
kay a former KGB and retired CIA
officers are getting together to write
books and they sit around and they will
probably talk about the good old days
and things like that and require a
cooperation and of course a lot of the
current issues of intelligence concern
do require a great deal of cooperation
between countries so liaison is always a
very important activity between people
and technically you're not supposed to
spy on your friends and it happens but
it is like what the Pollard case there's
always some kind of stink and the
Pollard case is a particularly awful one
an awful example of what when what
you're not supposed to do blows up in
your face but but the old the old guys
though in any profession I'd like to get
together I suppose and reminisce about
old times
probably they thought differently when
one thing when things were hot but there
is though there are stories of there are
stories about the old boy international
old boy networks that are that are still
that that is still around that that I've
heard over the years there any any other
questions yeah sure oh yeah well he's
one of those the you even even the
Reformers like why Gorbachev relied on
the the KGB to do is to do his will that
sort of Russia and eternal Russia kind
of kind of things of course the funny
irony is that the the net CIA
headquarters compound is now called the
George Bush center of five of for
intelligence or something like that by
legislative enactment and because he was
DCI for about eleven months but he was
one a man who was well liked and in ten
times were bad he always had a bad thing
to say about the Washington Post and
that made everybody very happy
so so he was he still still very very
popular out there though any yes David
approve policy I hate to publish
no no not at all really this is this
ancient history this is ancient history
almost prehistoric times is there's not
a lot of historical consciousness at the
CIA and the old the oh the the CIA
learned by suffering that you can't use
the review process censorship anymore so
so I story this ancient I really didn't
have any problems now now somebody not
your case officer who wants to wants to
write his memoirs that's that's a
different a different ball a ball of wax
but the immunity review process by by a
by struggle as has become much much more
better or better thought-out process
than it was five 10 years ago Ted cups
investigations into the deaths that had
been identified well it's not it's not
the sort of I do know from reading it
it's not the sort of story that the
information he he - he talks about is
not the kind of thing that the the CIA
want I wanted out and he of course not
being a CIA employee he didn't at his
book cleared so he and I'd but I don't
think it's going to be a book that's
going to be sold at the employee store
at the out at Langley anytime soon I I
wouldn't mind mine was but his I don't
think his is his is going to be very
time any any more questions okay
you all for coming again their books by
the door and absolutely thank you all
for coming out tonight I certainly
appreciate it
good
No
they're not